Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Hélène Vernet
Bonjour.
C'est un beau retour aux sources
pour moi de faire une présentation
ici, cet après-midi,
à quelques dizaines de mètres
de là où mon aventure humanitaire
personnelle a commencé,
il y a un peu plus de vingt ans.
En 1991, lors de ce qui est
maintenant considéré
comme l'avant-dernière grosse
débâcle depuis cette année,
à cette époque,
lorsque la rivière Chaudière
avait envahi le centre-ville
de Sainte-Marie,
la plupart des Mariverains,
comme ailleurs en Beauce,
avaient trouvé où passer les nuits
qu'ils ne pouvaient pas passer chez eux,
chez des parents, des amis,
des voisins, la parenté, etc.
Mais certains, un peu moins fortunés,
qui n'avaient pas ce réseau social,
étaient venus se réfugier
à la salle polyvalente
où la Croix-Rouge était venue
monter un centre d'hébergement.
J'y étais allé pour voir
si je pouvais donner un coup de main
et ce que je pouvais faire
pour faire ma part.
J'ai vu ce que la Croix-Rouge
faisait ici et à l'étranger,
et ça a été le coup de foudre,
une histoire qui dure depuis
maintenant plus de vingt ans.
C'est une histoire qui m'a amené
à travailler au Canada
mais aussi à travers le monde, dans
une trentaine de pays jusqu'à maintenant.
J'ai travaillé et répondu
à différentes catastrophes,
des tempêtes de verglas
jusqu'aux feux de forêts,
des inondations, tsunamis, sécheresses,
malheureusement aussi des guerres.
Ça m'a permis d'approfondir cette démarche
et mes réflexions sur mes
motivations, sur ce qu'on fait,
ce qu'on arrive à faire
et les limites de l'aide humanitaire.
Et je vais partager quelques-unes
de ces réflexions avec vous.
Quand on parle d'assistance humanitaire,
surtout dans le cadre
de la réponse d'urgence,
ce qui vient immédiatement à l'esprit,
c'est le tremblement
de terre à Haïti, en 2010.
Ça a été mon premier déploiement
en tant que chef d'opération.
J'avais comme mandat de monter
une opération de réponse d'urgence.
Donc, le 12 janvier 2010,
c'était une journée comme les autres,
je rentrais chez moi à pied et
j'étais à la recherche d'un appartement.
Je visitais un appartement
quand le téléphone s'est mis à vibrer.
J'ai regardé : Oh, « gros
tremblement de terre » !
Et tout d'un coup, après les courriels,
les SMS ont commencé à tomber.
Les SMS indiquent
que le niveau d'urgence s'élève.
Après ça, ça a été les coups de téléphone.
Là, j'ai dit à la dame
qui me faisait visiter l'appartement :
« On va arrêter là, car je pense que
demain matin, je dois partir à Haïti. »
Donc, je suis rentré au bureau,
et je me suis mis sur Skype,
et j'ai vu que tout le monde
était en ligne... c'était le soir.
Un de mes collègues qui était
à Port-au-Prince était connecté.
J'ai dit : « Comment ça va ? »
Il a dit « Ça va mal,
on a besoin d'aide. »
J'ai dit : « La cavalerie arrive »,
et il a répondu :
« Envoyez tout ce que vous avez. »
Là, ça m'a fait peur, car je savais
qu'il avait de l'expérience.
Quelques heures plus tard, j'ai un message
de mes patrons d'Ottawa et de Genève :
« Demain matin, tu prends l'avion pour
Saint-Domingue en République Dominicaine,
et tu vas monter
notre opération à Haïti. »
Je n'ai pas beaucoup dormi cette nuit-là !
On part le lendemain ; je retrouve
une équipe en train de s'assembler.
C'est drôle, ça fait quatre ans, mais,
j'ai encore de l'émotion qui remonte...
J'en ai parlé des dizaines de fois !
(Applaudissements)
Je suis sur timer là, je n'ai pas
le temps pour ces bêtises. (Rires)
OK, j'ai retrouvé mon équipe
à Saint-Domingue,
avec des gens qui arrivaient
de Panama et des États-Unis.
On monte dans un convoi,
on passe au supermarché.
On a pris tout ce qu'on pouvait
d'eau et de nourriture.
On descend à Port-au-Prince,
et on se signale.
On traverse la ville, et là, c'était
au-delà de tout ce que j'avais imaginer.
Personne de l'équipe n'avait jamais vu ça.
J'avais répondu au Tsunami,
en Indonésie, en 2006,
mais ça dépassait même ça,
vu la densité de la population,
et les difficultés qu'on avait
pour se frayer un chemin.
On a fini par arriver au futur
Centre des opérations.
Là, on a dit : « Par où on commence ? »,
« Ground Zero » de l'opération.
Je fais un rapport à Genève en disant :
« On est arrivé, on est prêt à opérer. »
Les patrons disent : « Tu as une avance
budgétaire de cent millions de dollars. »
Ha ! OK.
J'ai encore du mal à imaginer ce que
représentent concrètement 100 millions.
Tout de suite, non seulement
j'ai vu les besoins sur le terrain,
mais j'ai senti que les moyens
qu'on allait avoir à notre disposition,
l'argent, dans cette unique situation,
ne serait pas un élément qui permettait
de faire ou de ne pas faire quelque chose.
Ce serait juste une unité
de mesure de ce qu'on allait faire,
parce que quand on te dit
que tu as 100 millions,
tu opères, tu vois les besoins,
tu demandes, et tout vient.
Alors, au cours des
trois semaines suivantes,
tout ce qu'on avait, ou à peu près,
on l'a envoyé à Haïti.
Ça a été une mobilisation sans précédent
de la communauté internationale :
des hôpitaux, des avions,
des hélicoptères,
des bateaux, du matériel de construction,
de la nourriture, des génératrices,
ça a été un tel effort !
Dans un seul pays,
on n'avait jamais vu ça !
Ma première mission à Haïti
a duré trois semaines, 21 jours.
J'ai été rejoint par
300 personnes de 25 pays.
C'est assez phénoménal
de faire partie d'une équipe
où il y a des Israéliens, des Turcs,
des Norvégiens, des Colombiens,
des gens du monde entier,
tous venus pour travailler
dans la même direction,
et qui veulent tous
accomplir le même objectif.
Collectivement, on s'est installés
là où on le pouvait
parce que tout était par terre.
Ça, c'était un entrepôt désaffecté
dont un des murs, à moitié affaissé,
donnait directement sur Cité Soleil.
C'était le meilleur emplacement
que nous avions trouvé,
jusqu'à ce que l'équipe finisse
de monter un camp fonctionnel.
On est restés là durant
les deux premières semaines.
Au plus gros de notre premier camp,
nous étions 225 personnes
et on se partageait deux
douches et cinq latrines.
De fait, l'esprit d'équipe était là !
(Rires)
Durant ces deux semaines, pourtant,
je n'ai jamais entendu
personne se plaindre
des conditions de vie ou de travail.
C'était dur : les gens faisaient
des infections respiratoires,
on est tombés malades
les uns après les autres,
mais c'était tellement pire en dehors
que jamais personne ne s'est plaint.
Au fil des semaines, on s'est mobilisés.
Ça, c'est un hôpital de référence.
Quand je disais que l'argent
n'était pas un problème,
en fait, c'en est devenu un
parce qu'il y avait tellement de volonté
de répondre, tellement de ressources,
qu'il fallait essayer
de les canaliser, les prioriser.
Quand il n'y a qu'un aéroport dans
le pays, qui est à moitié fonctionnel,
quand il n'y a que deux routes
qui le lient à l'autre aéroport
qui est en République Dominicaine,
il faut choisir ce qui arrive,
parce que les premières heures,
les premiers jours,
on fait ce qu'on appelle
du « life-saving ».
Donc, si c'est mal coordonné,
mal géré, ça génère un blocage,
et on n'opère pas de façon optimale.
C'était une situation un peu surréelle,
où il y a une surabondance d'offre
qu'il faut absorber
et redistribuer sur le terrain.
C'était une mobilisation
à l'échelle de la planète.
En parlant avec Kevin,
hier, il me disait :
« C'est plutôt grisant, comme feeling.
C'est grisant. »
Je me suis retrouvé
au centre d'une mobilisation
qui réunissait les quatre
coins de la planète.
De la Thaïlande, de l'Australie,
de la Chine, de l'Amérique du Sud,
les gens convergeaient vers Haïti.
Cela crée une pression.
Tous les médias du monde sont sur toi.
Il y avait des caméras partout,
et tout le monde était à l'affût
d'histoires en temps réel.
Donc il y a une transmission
de l'horreur, de la solidarité,
d'histoires de courage,
d'histoires épouvantables,
tout ça sort
en continu sur les écrans.
Donc, tu te retrouves dans une vague
qui va au-delà de ce que tu représentes
comme force ou niveau d'énergie.
C'est une expérience d'une intensité
humaine que je n'ai jamais revécue,
et que je ne serais pas fâché
de ne jamais revivre non plus,
parce qu'après, revenu à la maison,
il m'a fallu six mois pour m'en remettre
et pour me rasseoir dans ma réalité.
Quand on a vécu ça,
ce rush d'action et d'intervention,
faire des comptes de dépenses,
des feuilles de temps,
et aller dans des réunions
de planification stratégique,
ça n'a pas beaucoup de sens.
Mais, éventuellement,
on se réajuste à sa réalité,
on réintègre le quotidien,
et on finit par l'absorber.
Donc, Haïti, pour moi, c'est un extrême.
Je pense que c'est ce qui
représente le plus facilement
l'imaginaire collectif de ce
qu'on pense être « l'humanitaire ».
L'humanitaire, pourtant, ce n'est pas
que des situations comme Haïti.
Cette année, de janvier
à mars, j'ai été déployé
en République Centrafricaine
où depuis plusieurs mois,
il y a de la violence et des
conflits entre les communautés,
des gens pris dans une spirale
de vengeance et de représailles,
des dizaines de milliers de personnes
déplacées dans le pays,
des dizaines de milliers d'autres
qui ont dû se réfugier dans d'autres pays.
Et entre autres, parmi ces gens-là,
il y a des dizaines de milliers
de personnes dans un camp, à l'aéroport.
Ma mission était de monter
l'opération de la Croix-Rouge
et de me demander :
« Que peut-on faire ? »
J'ai été là sept semaines,
et malgré tous mes efforts
durant ces sept semaines,
je n'ai pu mobiliser
qu'une seule personne.
Cette personne était spécialiste
en soins psychosociaux
puisque ce qu'il était venu faire -
et pour moi, le besoin était criant -
c'était d'appuyer les secouristes locaux
qui eux, depuis des mois, tous les jours,
montaient dans leur pick-up,
allaient chercher des blessés
ou les cadavres des gens
massacrés pendant la nuit.
Les besoins des gens
sur le site de l'aéroport
ne sont pas différents de ceux en Haïti.
Leurs aspirations sont les mêmes,
mais la réponse n'est pas là.
C'est assez particulier à gérer.
Et le contraste dans ces réponses
était d'autant plus fort pour moi
que, pour des raisons de sécurité,
on était dans un hôtel luxueux
protégé par l'armée,
vu qu'on n'avait pas
d'autre endroit où aller.
Le soir, après le couvre-feu,
quand on se retrouvait, à six heures,
pour essayer de planifier la journée,
voir ce qu'on pensait,
il y avait un orchestre
qui jouait en fond,
et pas si loin que ça,
on entendait les explosions
et on voyait la lumière
des balles traçantes
pendant que la violence
continuait dans les rues.
Ça, c'est un autre côté de l'humanitaire
dont on parle moins, qu'on voit moins.
Mais quand on décide
de s'engager dans cette carrière,
ça fait partie de ce à quoi on s'expose.
Ce que j'essaie de vous
transmettre aujourd'hui -
j'allais oublier de dire
que pendant ce temps,
la planète regardait
les Jeux Olympiques de Sotchi,
50 milliards de dollars pour
l'organisation des Jeux Olympiques...
et la Centrafrique... ? -
donc ce que je voulais vous dire,
c'est que j'ai vécu ces extrêmes,
d'un extrême à l'autre.
Cela vous donne une autre image
de ce qu'on considère, en fait,
comme une carrière
ou un engagement assez romantique,
beaucoup diffusé par les médias.
On voit des vedettes
et des célébrités venir,
et ça inspire,
ça pousse les gens à vouloir aider.
Je ne dis pas qu'il ne faut pas de bonnes
intentions : ça commence avec elles.
Sauf qu'il y a un risque
au modèle de l'aide humanitaire,
c'est celui de la charité
dont Marie-Laure parlait,
celui de la victimisation.
Quand on se déploie sur le terrain
avec nos avions,
nos hélicoptères, nos ressources,
il est facile de mettre ceux qu'on
va aider dans une position d'infériorité.
Hélène disait en début d'après-midi :
« On devient aveugle à la personne
derrière son handicap. »
Eh bien, le risque de l'assistance
ou du modèle caritatif
qu'il y a dans l'humanitaire,
c'est de ne voir dans cette personne
qui a tout perdu qu'une victime.
Et personne ne veut être une victime.
Personne ne veut
se considérer comme telle,
et on n'aide pas les gens
quand on les victimise ;
on tombe dans « l'assistancialisme ».
Il faut s'éloigner de ça
et leur donner les outils
dont ils ont besoin
pour surmonter l'épreuve qu'ils ont vécue,
et les accompagner
pour préserver leur dignité,
donc, aller voir la personne derrière.
J'insiste sur le fait que c'est important
d'avoir de bonnes intentions,
mais il faut être lucide.
Pour le reste, il y a des techniques
et de l'expérience qui s'apprend.
Je pense que c'est un métier avec
des leçons apprises au fil des années.
Il y a moyen de se
perfectionner techniquement,
mais la façon dont on considère
notre propre rôle,
c'est là que ça fait une différence.
Ce que lui veut, la tente, le kit d'eau,
évidemment, c'est important,
mais ce qu'il cherche,
c'est la sécurité économique,
la sienne, celle de sa famille,
celle de ses enfants,
comme vous, comme moi,
bien plus que la tente, bien plus
que le kit de cuisine qu'on lui donne.
Ça fait quinze ans que je fais
du terrain à l'international,
ça fait vingt ans
que je fais de l'humanitaire,
et encore cette année, en Centrafrique,
j'ai saisi cette dimension de l'importance
de la dignité mais d'une autre façon,
parce que quand on est enfermé
dans un hôtel, le soir,
après le couvre-feu,
on a le temps de beaucoup réfléchir.
Un soir, pour la première
fois cette année-là,
il y a eu de la pluie, la saison
des pluies a commencé.
Je répondais d'habitude
durant les périodes de sécheresse,
donc la pluie était la bienvenue.
Mais là, j'ai réalisé
que la pluie allait transformer
le camp des personnes déplacées
à l'aéroport, en champ de boue.
Et pour la première fois,
maintenant qu'une petite fille
d'un an m'attend à la maison,
je me suis mis dans la peau
de ce père de famille
qui ne pouvait pas faire en sorte
que son enfant passe la nuit au sec,
et ça ma fait mal.
Ça m'a fait mal d'une façon que
je n'avais jamais ressentie auparavant.
En même temps, le fait
d'avoir mon enfant à la maison
m'a aussi fait reconsidérer
le niveau de risque
auquel je suis prêt à m'exposer
dans le cadre de mes activités,
et repenser à mon propre travail,
car je pense qu'il est temps
que je fasse autre chose
plutôt que d'aller m'exposer au danger.
Ma mère va être contente
de l'apprendre aussi !
(Rires)
Donc, c'est dans cette position
que je me trouve pour vous dire,
eh bien une démarche authentique,
c'est aussi de continuer à se questionner.
Après toutes ces années
passées à courir la planète,
j'ai encore plus de questions
et moins de certitudes qu'avant.
Mais je vais vous dire autre chose.
Je suis venu à Pâques, ici,
il y a deux semaines,
pour aller à la fabrique
de sirop d'érable,
et en passant par le centre-ville,
j'ai vu les gens qui nettoyaient
leurs caves, s'aidaient entre voisins,
s'arrachaient les laines de roche...
Il y avait des récupérateurs de bouffe...
des récupérateurs de déchets, pardon !
(Rires)
J'ai vu des récupérateurs de déchets,
et j'ai vu justement l'entraide.
Vous allez trouver ça bizarre,
mais j'ai trouvé ça beau de voir ça !
Ça fait du bien d'être à la maison !
Je vous remercie.
(Applaudissements)